you said your grandmother emily
had a big impact on your life she lived
to 102. what are some lessons
she taught you emily who was the the
child of immigrants from
from russia and poland who never went to
college
uh her proudest day i think was when
when i went to college um
she um she treated
everyone with respect and tried to get
to know everyone she knew every bus
driver
in the town she'd remember their
birthdays
and one of the things she taught me is
no matter how high you fly
the lowest person close to the ground
matters to you
and uh you treat them the same way you
treat the
billionaire at the top of the podium and
she she did that she didn't just say
that
some people say then don't do it she she
really did that and i always
remember that it comes up in my mind at
least once a week because
we're all busy doing a lot of things and
you either see
or you even feel in yourself the desire
to just for the reasons of speed
to be short or not polite with someone
who can't do anything to to harm you
right now
and i remember uh her saying to me no
you you don't you you you treat everyone
with respect you treat you know
the person you're on the phone with
right customer service you treat that
person if you're talking to jeff bezos
so you're talking to
elon musk right uh and and i think
making that a culture of who you are is
so important and people notice that
that's the other thing
and they notice when it's authentic
everyone's nice to the person at the
bottom of the
totem pole when you want to get a head
in the line for your driver's license
yeah but are you nice to them when you
don't need that they notice that
and even when nobody's watching that has
a weird effect on you
that's going to uh have a ripple effect
and people know
that's the cool thing about the internet
i've come to believe that people see
authenticity they see
when you're full of when you're not
that's right the other thing that that
emily taught me and i think we've all
had relatives
have taught us this right that you could
be very uneducated she was very
uneducated she you know she had a high
school diploma
but i think she was working in you know
in a delicatessen in new york you know
while she was in high school or maybe it
was at gimbals or something so she might
not take high school very seriously she
wasn't very well educated
she was very smart and we can fall into
a world
where i'm a big believer in higher
education and getting a phd and things
of that sort
but where we think those are the only
smart people no
sometimes those are the people because
of their accomplishments because their
egos are the ones
who are least educated
in the way of the world yeah least
curious
and not ultimately wisdom comes from
curiosity
and sometimes getting a phd can get away
it can get in the way of curiosity as
opposed to empower curiosity
you